I believe this programme
is probably one of the best things
that has happened to me in my life.
You make a lot of new friends.
You gain confidence.
You experience new cultures.
My expectations and hopes
included meeting new people
and improving my English.
I already knew some English,
but I wanted to improve.
I chose this programme
because the challenge for me
was to be away from home
and my family
for a period of time.
We're from five different cultures
and speak five different languages,
but this isn't a negative thing.
It's positive
because it's an opportunity for learning.
The aim of the project
is to develop these soft skills -
confidence in yourself and in others,
the ability to interact
with different cultures
and the self-confidence
to take on challenges
through games and
especially street arts,
such as clownery,
juggling and acrobatics.
In clownery you need to come out
of your comfort zone to an extent.
You must dare to be ridiculous,
dare to fail,
fail also in a funny way,
to laugh at yourself, laugh at others.
I learnt how to be myself with others
and not have to pretend
to be somebody else.
And I learnt how to be open with other
people, which is the main thing.
I think we're all essentially the same.
We're different
in terms of our customs and traditions,
but as people we're not different at all.
You learn a lot more
about your European neighbours
and you feel more part
of the European community.
My greatest moment
will have to be last night on the stage
when we all came together.
It was like a climax of this exchange.
There was a great energy
behind the stage.
All the hard work we put in
and all the friends we made.
We really showed that on the stage.
We've seen a lot of young people
who through the Erasmus and Youth in
Action exchange and
training programmes
have changed and grown
and have followed very different paths.
Some didn't want to go to university,
but now have enrolled,
some have gone on an EVS year,
people who didn't know anything
about Erasmus before
or couldn't speak English.
It's only because they've done
something different
that they have decided
to take on these challenges.
Erasmus+!